👏👏👏👏
it's friday everybody.
You know what that means?
(OMG PLAY THE INTRO DO IT)
FRIDAY WITH PEWDIEPIE
FRIDAY WITH PEWDIEPIEEE* omg yes im crying*
That's right everybody, I'm bringing back the old time favorite of this channel
fridays with pewdiepie*yayyyyyy*
The fridays with me pewdiepie that's me
guys i had a promise that i made
Seven years ago
i made a promise
that if i hit a hundred thousand subscribers
I was going to strip on camera*oh god i remember*
(old pewds)how's it going everyone
(new pewds)but it looks like i'm already stripping look
how much skin i'm showing look at that shaven chest you
the pure the pure feelix
(old pewds)and welcome to
Fridays with Pewdiepie
Can't even understand what he's saying
the accent is so thick
i literally don't understand what he's saying.
who is this guy?
okay that was pretty dumb
I Will fight old pewdiepie any day.
i thought i'll do this
vlog if sort of things at least once a week okay i actually upload a
two-minute q&a*laughs*
Wait but it's two minutes long when will you strip for us* continues laughing*
*old pewdipie looks so cute*
if i get
100,000 subscribers i'll do it guys
Next fridays with pewdiepie i'm going to strip it's going, to be epic?*why not this one*
check it out guys alright leave your entries in the sub redit bros
*LWIAY intro plays*
okay let's see what kind of memes you guys posted this week
predictions!!
I don't know actually i'm let's just check it out thank you guys it's so nice that we have friday's with pewdiepie
as a community thing you know but we really appreciate each other
It's wonderful i'm so glad i kept it going up vote if you want marzia, to hmmmm in a video
*alien voices*
*he's done with this*
Please wait
*please wait again* *is he calling marzia*
*marzia voice hmmmming*
*marzia laughing*
*pewds laughing at marzia*
that was not good Marzia
that was terrible i'm really glad these
reposts of memes make it into pewdiepie submissions cuz they're
so funny are you guys excited for i don't get it it just says three and markiplier i
Don't can you guys explain this to me cuz i don't seem to understand what are you doing later i want to go to dinner
You don't do dinner why
That's too bad i don't usually ask twice but um
fuck yeah that's my tank
*pewds laugh* *i laugh*
Oh so now you're interested. Oh she likes tanks well
No tanks *cringe* no tanks everybody great all these
gold-digging women sorry i don't mean to say that all
women are gold diggers but it's it's clear soon as soon as you roll off with at t3 e3
Sorry as, soon as you roll up with at t3 e2 tank all the sudden is different is this cosplay
*close up*
fine you did it you did a clever cosplay you made it into LWAIY... WHY IS THIS IN LWAIY?
I have this theory for a long time that we need to send kids off to an island*its in his deleted tweets video*
where they fight for their life and only the strong will make it out alive fort damn it i created fortnight
*clap clap* meme review
The end of civilization the end there's no hope for the youth there's no hope for the future
So this is the army of 9 y/o *laughs*
with, too simple class you could command an army
*laughs* *dr Phil to the rescue*
when you run out of content
Hit that Phil everybody hey it's working okay and it's funny i enjoy it so shut up guys
stop bullying
Producer: why do you want a car that's
$399,000? Because i like the design of the lines. Look at those lines guys my chair as well?
It's he's a little shy, okay give him time
*laughs*
brad one brad two my 3.3 k uploaded post oh
See this is what i'm saying
you can't blame me you gotta take it up with brad one and two tweet at them *we will xD*
Know the chair meme is outdated oh?
boy
Oh, boy what is it what is it it's never going
To be out it's clearly been immortalize at this point just keep going i don't even care
oh
wow that's nice
I mean honestly another reason why it's such a great price look how much you can use it for $399 everybody
*tries to understand the joke*
*is it LOSS** LOL*
oh, my god it's lost no, oh my god * I KNEW IT**I KNEW IT*
I wouldn't have realized damn it err
Damn it i kept refreshing *IM so happy I got it* ITS SO ANNOYING!
Is this a funny meme there's some seriously high uploaded ones this week ok, so who's that
some random guy okay the pope
pope means putin putin means trump trump means meatza kim jong kim jo means
south, korea president south korea president means obama obama means conan conan meets felix oh my god
I've shipped the same hand as kim jong*wow*
that was great i actually really enjoy that well done handsome jack's first animation everybody
That was hype since Ali-A is using pewdiepies intro i decided to make a new one he can't steal ha got you ali-a
good that's so good*amazing* you need to start working on your own idea
can we copy strike dreamworks then
that is pretty crazy to be honest
I need to grow out my beer just tad bit more
upvote if you want brad to make a video and pewdiepie to edit it well i think i'm gonna edit a video that takes effort
okay not gonna happen dear pewds we as your fans and your nine-year-old
army has realized that you as our leader has been less
enthusiastic and energetic we know and understand that getting married must be very hard and stressful and you two must be
exhausting when you are sad and drop hints about stressful life we care and and
We see and we care take a day two days even a week off if that means you will feel better we love you
that is very sweet *we really love you*
Kept dropping these jokes at the end of the video where i would say oh i'm here tomorrow guys i do this every single day
i really appreciate their concern and i'm really glad that i have an audience that
don't like get mad at me if they notice something they just show compassion and i appreciate that but
it was the same thing when i made jokes about
running out of ideas i don't know if you guys remember that was like a year ago everyone kept joking i
Kept joking that i was running out of ideas and they became a meme so as soon as i posted a video that was like
hardly inspired a bit uninspired everyone kept going "HE'S OUT OF IDEAS OH MY GOD!" and it just kept getting
reinforced as fact that i was running out of ideas when the reality
a ton of ideas for videos lined up like it was not a problem* we know it pewds*
And i kept making this joke at the end of the video now where i say i'm here every single day guys every single day
I let it just made the joke because i don't pre record my videos i upload
Like this videos see now it's up it's recorded either the same day or the day before
Because it keeps them more fresh and entertaining that way i used to pre-record back in the day for example and a lot of youtubers
Do but the fact that i record every single day i think it's kind of fun in a way you know it keeps
going and it's kept going for so long without a stop and i kind of wanted just to remind people
I'm here tomorrow
check out tomorrow's video but then a lot of people i've seen a lot of people coming about this saying oh he seems really tired
Or he seems like really a none energetic wait isn't the true at all if anything i didn't really want to force the whole
hey hey everybodyy
if i didn't feel like it
And sometimes i just don't don't get me wrong sometimes i really enjoy being a retard on camera fully
100% but a lot of times i just want to act more normal and it's interesting how if i act more
"normal" it's like there's something wrong with me or something like that but that's a really long answer thank you guys for the
The love i appreciate it nontheless okay everybody thank you guys
So much for submitting all the memes really enjoy them it's always
So much fun and i'll see you guys tomorrow guys tomorrow i'm gonna be here tomorrow
That's right i'm here every single day i'm here forever it never ends it never stops
*we love you for that* BRO FIST! *he did a bro fist!*
*outro plays*
*if your out of ideas you can make a vid on us LOL*
*Download A$$*
*this is eva signing off, take care everyone*
*bro fist*
*take care* *outro ends*